for a given input value b
the function f outputs a value a to
satisfy the following equation 4a plus
7b is equal to negative 52. so for given
input b
the function f the function f will
output an a that satisfies
this relationship right over here for
the a and the b
write a formula for f of b in terms of b
so we want to do is we just want to
solve for if we're given a b what a does
that imply that we have to output or
another way to think about it is let's
just solve this for a
or we could think about a as being a
function of b
so let's write this so we have 4 a
plus 7b
is equal to negative 52. so if i can
solve for a in terms of b then any b
that i have let's say the b's are on the
right-hand side i can put it in i can
substitute that value for b and then i
can just solve for a i can solve for the
a that needs to be outputted so let's do
that let's solve for a so i want to get
all the a i want i want to just have an
a left over on the left hand side and
we'll have everything else on the right
hand side including the b's so let's get
rid of this b on the left hand side
and i can do that by subtracting 7b now
of course i want to do that to both
sides i can't just do an equation and do
an operation only on one side like that
so let's subtract and we are left with
we are left with the seven b's add up to
zero seven b minus seven b and we are
left with four a
is equal to negative 52
minus seven b
minus 7b
now to isolate the a here to just have
an a here instead of a 4a we can divide
both sides by 4.
we can divide both sides by 4 so i'm
just going to divide everything
by 4
and on the left hand side we got our
goal we are left with an a
is equal to now what's negative 54
divided by what's the negative 52
divided by four so let's think about it
52 is 40 plus 12. 40 divided by 4 is 10
12 divided by 4 is 3 so it's going to be
13 negative 13. so it's negative
minus seven fourths b
so given a b if you give me a b i can
put that value right over here and then
i can calculate what the corresponding a
needs to be in order to satisfy this
relationship so if i want a formula for
f of b in terms of b i could say look
you give me a b
the output of our function which is f of
a the output of our function is going to
be is going to be negative 13
minus 7 4b
because the output of our function needs
to be an a
that will satisfy
this equation up here
so hopefully that helped